parliament will look at the eu response
to the war in ukraine meps will discuss
protecting children and young refugees
as well as support for the kiev
government sanctions against vladimir
putin's regime and diplomatic efforts to
end russian aggression
securing europe's energy independence
has never been so important meps will
vote on legislation designed to
modernize the eu's cross-border energy
infrastructure like hydrogen pipelines
clean gas and smart electricity grids
the potential rewards from europe's
ever-growing data banks are huge from
improving healthcare to revolutionizing
transport parliament will vote on
legislation facilitating the sharing and
using of big data while safeguarding
privacy
last month the taliban government went
back on its commitment to allow girls
over the age of 11 to return to school
meps will examine the erosion of women's
and girls rights since the taliban
returned to power
77 of europeans would prefer to fix
rather than replace products to put an
end to the throwaway society meps are
set to call for the right to repair
consumer items like phones toasters and
microwaves giving them a longer life
[Music]